GAYLE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
RAMY INOCENCIO REPORTING FROM
BEIJING.
THANK YOU.
>>> THE PRESIDENT HAS TAPPED
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS TO
LEAD THE EFFORT TO STEM ILLEGAL
MIGRATION INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
HERE'S WHAT SHE TOLD US
EXCLUSIVELY ABOUT THAT ISSUE
JUST YESTERDAY MORNING --
>> OKAY, LOOK, IT'S A HUGE
PROBLEM.
ARE WE LOOKING AT OVERCROWDING
AT THE BORDER, IN PARTICULAR OF
THESE KIDS?
YES.
SHOULD THESE KIDS BE IN THE
CUSTODY OF HHS, THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NINSTEAD OF THE
THE BORDER PATROL?
YES.
>> THE MEDIA WAS ALLOWED INSIDE
A SHELTER FOR MIGRANT KIDS FOR
THE FIRST TIME DURING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
JANET SHAMLIAN IS AT THE BORDER
BRICK AND MO
IN THE U.S. AND MEXICO.
>> Reporter: THIS WAS HIGHLY
CONTROLLED ACCESS INSIDE A
FACILITY RUN BY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
IT SHOWED CHILDREN RUNNING AND
PLAYING IN WELL-EQUIPPED
FACILITIES.
QUITE A CONTRAST TO THE IMAGES
WE SAW EARLIER INSIDE A FACILITY
RUN BY CUSTOMS AND BORDER
CONTROL WHICH APPEARED
OVERCROWDED WITH CHILDREN
SLEEPING ON THE FLOOR.
HERE ALONG THE BORDER, THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH SPACE RIGHT NOW TO
KEEP UP WITH THE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE CROSSING OVER
EACH DAY.
THIS MORNING, THERE ARE MORE
THAN 16,000 UNACCOMPANIED
MIGRANT CHILDREN IN U.S. HOLDING
FACILITIES.
LIKE THIS ONE IN CARRRIZO
SPRINGS, TEXAS.
ON WEDNESDAY, JUST ONE NETWORK
CAMERA WAS ALLOWED INSIDE.
THE NUMBER OF MIGRANT CROSSINGS
ARE SURGING.
CBS NEWS ON A RIDE-ALONG WITH
TEXAS TROOPERS WATCHING THE FLOW
ALONG THE RIO GRANDE.
>> WE'VE COME ACROSS CHILDREN
UNDER 10 THAT HAVE BEEN JUST
BASICALLY DUMPED THERE AND GONE
ON.
SO THAT TAKES A TOLL.
>> Reporter: EACH DAY, A NUMBER
OF MIGRANTS ARE TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY THEN FLOWN TO SAN DIEGO
AND EL PASO.
MANY SINGLE ADULTS AND SOME
FAMILIES ARE THEN EXPELLED BACK
INTO MEXICO AS PART OF THE
TRUMP-ERA 42 POLICY WHICH IS
STILL IN PLACE AND ALLOWS ASYLUM
SEEKERS TO BE DENIED DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
OTHERS ARE ABLE TO GO THROUGH
IMMIGRATION PROCEEDINGS LIKE
THIS MOM AND HER SON FROM
GUATEMALA.
FOR SAFETY, SHE ASKED NOT TO BE
IDENTIFIED BUT TOLD US SHE PAID
A SMUGGLER MORE THAN $3,000 TO
GET THEM ACROSS THE BORDER.
A HEART WRENCHING DECISION.
SHE LEFT HER TWO YOUNGER
CHILDREN BEHIND AS SHE HEADS TO
MEET RELATIVES IN ALABAMA.
RUBEN GARCIA RUNS ENUNCIATION
HOUSE WITH SHELTERS IN EL PASO
AND JUAREZ.
HE FEARS WHAT'S HAPPENING E AT
THE BORDER NOW IS ONLY THE
START.
WHEN YOU SEE THE SITUATION
UNFOLDING, WHAT KEEPS YOU UP AT
NIGHT?
>> THAT TITLE 42 WILL BE CHANGED
WITHOUT PLANNING.
BECAUSE IF IT'S NOT HAPPENING
AND THERE IS CHAOS, THEN ONE OF
THE ACCUSATIONS IS GOING TO BE
YOU KNEW, YOU KNEW THAT THIS WAS
A VERY REAL POSSIBILITY, AND YOU
DID PLAN FOR IT.
>> Reporter: AND GARCIA SAYS
THERE IS A BOTTLENECK OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CENTRAL AMERICAN
MIGRANTS JUST ACROSS THE BORDER.
AND THAT'S NOT THE ONLY CONCERN.
THE PANDEMIC IS, AS WELL.
THE TEXAS FACILITY YESTERDAY,
MORE THAN 100 OF THE BOYS WHO
WERE THERE WERE IN